je vais faire l'action politique se
mettre la main à la porte concrètement
en 20 minutes à une demi-heure de deux
ans voici ce que tu peux faire de
maintenant toutes flafla plus
d'obstacles une structure le
militantisme politique ne se fait plus
comme avant il ya moins d'adhésion
partisane et les parties doivent
repenser leur machine électorale
on lance ce matin la plateforme
mouvement je vais voir qu'il ya un
événement qui existe déjà
soirée d'appel aux sympathisants chago
bon c'est l'idée qu'a partir de
n'importe où au québec vous allez
pouvoir vous organiser ça peut être une
assemblée de cuisine ça peut être une
soirée de pointage ça peut être
tractage à l'extérieur pas besoin de
demande énormément de personnes qui
croient qu'ils forment aussi peut être
un crime et on est parti exc ça me
semble l'outil parfait pour les deux
formes du patient selon ce qu'on peut
voir aussi ce logiciel comme un aveu qui
manquent de militants chez québec
solidaire c'est un aveu que de plus en
plus de gens surtout dans ma génération
ne se reconnaissent plus dans la manière
traditionnelle dont les parties fonceur
si beaucoup plus est
militante facebook j'ai l'impression que
facebook a perdu sa crédibilité pour
nous ressemble et la technologie les
métadonnées change la donne c'est la
campagne électorale de barack obama en
2008 qui a vraiment marqué le coup
maintenant le parti libéral comme le
parti québécois aussi ont des outils
pour mieux cerner leurs électeurs et les
géolocaliser et tout ça dans le but
d'optimiser le porte-à-porte les appels
téléphoniques et les publicités tous les
partis politiques maintenant utilisent
les médias sociaux les nouvelles
technologies les enquêtes plus poussées
sur la population
la cac qui est un jeune parti avec une
base militante moins forte a acquis au
coût d'un million de dollars cet automne
un logiciel pour centraliser les données
sur les électeurs et orienter le massage
sur le terrain on commence à coûter
cette application lancée le chef
je suis pour une question quelques
dizaines de milliers de la caq parler de
son arme secrète est ce que c'est votre
arme nucléaire
allez c'est notre âme mais sinon non
secret parce qu'on fait le pari
justement la transparence totale
on leur dit c'est fini l'époque où les
employés de partis politiques ne vous
dira comment vous organisez puis comment
faire
[Musique]